always announce it here first my road
dates because you guys are my engaged
listeners and that's what makes sense
and you're gonna come see me in the next
couple of weeks i am in vegas july 15th
at the brand new virgin hotel uh july
16th at the celebrity theater in phoenix
arizona and then in boulder colorado on
the 17th
at the boulder theater the following
week or actually the following few days
later july 20th i'm in portland at the
arlene schnitzer concert hall i haven't
been to portland in a minute i love you
guys you're always asking me to come i'm
there tell a friend as well if you hear
this city tell your friend they don't
want to miss me i promise you seattle
washington on july 21st the paramount
theater the vogue theater in vancouver
my first ever canadian solo date on july
22nd
i'll be at in canada a few months from
now again in hamilton and toronto in
october and then there's a bunch of new
dates that were just announced for the
fall really quickly it's richmond
virginia hershey pa knoxville tennessee
atlanta birmingham louisville evansville
jacksonville tampa orlando sacramento
san jose and santa rosa those are all on
sale right now and they're all not
coming until the fall so you can get
those tickets
right away they're the good tickets and
i'll see you guys in july i appreciate
you guys come laugh
hey baby go to
chrisdcomedy.com i am in montreal at the
end of july i am in burlington vermont
and i got brilliant improv in august and
we got san francisco in september and we
got chicago theater in september we got
more dates coming soon but montreal and
vermont on sale now july 27th and 29th
chrisdcomedy.com for tiki wiki is also
my special especially out on netflix
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's up baby how are you doing first
of all the haircut
looks
fresh it looks hello fresh
wow america's number one haircut
[Laughter]
um what was the woe i asked i asked for
the mediterranean shrimp scampi uh he
cut my hair in 20 minutes 20 very
convenient right in my doorstep i didn't
have to leave my home that's what it is
bubbas you got a haircut too we haven't
seen each other in a minute but you look
like you got a new haircut i got a
haircut two weeks ago high and tight
babe high and schmidty yeah um i uh rosa
ripped me forward i don't know why well
does derozan even have hair i don't know
he has he has something on his head on
top rose is one of those guys like he
you know he has hair but he looks bald
he's skinny but he feels fat
you know like he's just one of those
guys where like you think like you like
if you said if you said hey joe derose
is short bald and fat i'd like yay yes
[Laughter]
but then when you meet him he's tall has
hair and not fat yeah yeah yeah but he
just has the personality of just a sh
he has the soul of a short fat bold
person
you know and
it's so visceral that it almost takes
over his physical appearance yeah yeah
that's interesting it's interesting um
very very observant
i am so what so far this week what has
been it's only thursday but what has
been the best can you pick one moment of
your week that's been the best it's very
hard to pick a moment oh my god i'm
talking about a
16 to 9 no a five second
or less
moment of your week can you even think
of one oh because i i i am assuming this
means that you have something
locked and loaded i'm gonna think of
mine while you think of yours okay well
moments ago i don't think it was the
best day well i had some good shows this
weekend but that's lame i bought a
little kid on stage okay and it was uh
oh it was good it was i ended up taking
like 20 minutes before that kid got off
the stage it was one of those things
that just kept giving and giving and
giving did you get it did you tape it
uh i recorded it i didn't tape it i know
but i know it would have been a nice
tick tock i know
but moments ago i just found out i think
i've been asked or at least i'm in the
in the in the running to host the uh
roast of ric flair
i don't know if i should even say that
this came across my phone moments ago
comedy sense uh no it's gonna be like on
uh
like a pay-per-view like it's stark at
like a fight tv and triller and all that
stuff okay that kind of thing that's
sick that's a great moment
yeah but i don't even know if she didn't
say that because i don't know if i'm
taking the job i don't know if they're
really offering me the job i didn't talk
about anything but i just got it and i
was like whoa i wasn't expecting i was
kind of city and state would it be
nashville
july 29th at the fairgrounds how hot is
it going to be july 29th in new york
at the fairgrounds too bro
if you guys don't go to that you can go
july 29th come see me at club soda in
montreal nice
club soda that's the name of the venue
i'm doing in montreal just for are you
not doing the just for last comedy
festival this year no i'm doing
vancouver on july 22nd and then in
october i'm doing hamilton and toronto
but i'm not part of the jfl if you will
i've never ever been to vancouver and
it's some place it's gorgeous then i'd
love to go i went for vacation
i did everything i took a seaplane to a
to a little island i swam in like
freezing cold waters i went up in the
mountains i went to the world's biggest
like suspect like foot suspension bridge
uh i did all sorts of fun stuff in
vancouver do you know they have a
beautiful little it's it's much like
seattle they have this cool little
downtown area and the the hills are
separated by water and then in the
middle there's this like
little thing you go to i forget what
it's called but all these different
shops and food markets and it's really
really cool so you're saying vancouver's
a must i loved it
really yeah i loved it would you keep it
if if if they're become like if a
warlord takes over the world which could
happen one day and they start picking
off cities would you fight and die for
the city of vancouver no you'd let it go
yeah but i wouldn't fight and die for
any city you wouldn't find a guy for any
city no what about new york no what
about paris
party yeah maybe but that's the city of
romans what about london
[Laughter]
no would you would you fight for a city
and die for it
because wait are you saying that i could
just migrate to another city or just i
could skirt it and die i'm saying
there's a warlord i don't want to die
there's a warlord going around the world
and he's k he's wise
he's a warlord and he cannot be stopped
and each city that he goes to um take
over the people of that city are getting
slaughtered yeah but they're defending
the city but you can join the resistance
and defend certain cities that you like
all right well new york should have a
pretty big resistance right bronx alone
yeah the bronx along right
true or false and kids email this to
heybaypod gmail.com who has more guns
right now ukraine or the bronx yeah i
mean that's gonna be i mean ukraine
ukraine is as you see you saw the last
news uh report ukraine is pleading to
the bronx to send over weapons you're
like yo 161st street we need you
um
ric flair doesn't know his real name
because he was adopted on the black
market is that true if so that's my
leading
that's my leading thing what do you mean
he's
what does that even mean adopted on the
black market can you make that far
bigger pimp
he was adopted shortly after he was born
in 1949 february of 1949 in memphis
tennessee and his adoption was arranged
by the tennessee children's home society
in orphanage that was involved in
kidnapping babies and often up to those
looking to adopt could you imagine
you're just a mom and dad and you go to
adopt a baby and you adopt baby infant
ric flair
how insane would that be that would be
he's in like that he's in like the like
like like the crib with like a
like a bedazzled diaper yeah just like
with before he's like when he cries he's
like
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he survived a plane crash in 1975. wow
yeah 1975 survived a plane crash um
which is the year salvagano was born 76
but you were you were in you were you
might have been
i was in you october 9 17 were you
swimming in your dad's nuts were you
already implanted october 79 79 75
october 25 were you not swimming or were
you implanted i was nuts you were not so
okay but that's so good you were still
kind of you were i was in the
conversation in the area yeah he also
survived the lightning strike the only
thing rick flair's naked will survive is
the roast by salvo
should i take it i would take it hell
yeah dude you're a huge wrestling fan
yeah that's like if they asked me to
roast george washington
[Laughter]
i know i feel like i should i don't know
if it's like hey we want you to do this
but it said you're in the running we're
looking for it said we're looking for
someone to be the roast master
we know that you like wrestling and you
could do it do you have any interest let
us know we'll give you all the
information here's the thing you have
the interest but
do we have the time because to write a
roast of ric flair and you being the
roast master you got to come out
swinging got to come out hard this might
be
the d stands for delegation on this one
okay you might you want to put that d in
those jokes and by d i i do mean dick
but i also mean delegation right right
so i think that might be
you know we have a team of people coming
out and cut because it's very i mean
dude yeah right those jokes to be the
roastmaster it's got to be your focus
for two weeks yeah yeah yeah and you can
you already said you do in vancouver
july 22nd you can't do it i know and i'm
coming back and then yeah i mean it's
rough i mean i am free that weekend i
think
but it's time for the weekend's enough
to write ric flair roastmaster jokes if
you were just on the panel i'd say you
cannot get out on the plane right the
roast master yeah because then i gotta
hit everybody else and i'll tell you who
else is gonna be there let's see let's
some of the people that are supposed to
let me do a couple of guesses um
uh um who else is on it jim norton
no there's no other comics yet no okay
but some of the people that are beyond
the that might be like on the deus or
something
it's well it's not mentioning any other
comics or wrestlers but non comics and
non wrestlers
charles barkley okay charlie we can
roast him up good okay we can roast rock
kid rock we can we can roast him charlie
sheen oh my god you have aids yeah iced
tea oh iced tea hit him with all hate
him with jokes about lipton
snoop dogg snoop dogg absolutely dennis
rodman dennis rodman i mean we could we
could listen to all those people yeah
you can lace into them i also though i
put myself in the crosshairs though but
i mean come at me
come at me you can't say anything to me
i haven't heard before come at me snoop
dogg
um i think that that's uh uh honestly
see here's the thing how do you feel
initially the first moment when you got
that email what did you say i was like
oh my god because he's a legend you know
and i was like that would be really fun
like i was like immediately trying to
think of like jokes right but then i'm
like i have
no time i'm filming so i'd have to be
home like i'm i'm i have no time it's
it's i'd be squeezing that in in the in
the one percent of time that i have who
are you going to give it to if you could
trade it off to anybody who would you
give it to the rose to rick flair who
would you just gift it to
i'd probably give it to another comic
that is a wrestling fan
big j roy wood jr well they're not
wrestling fans though are they not big j
just looks like a wrestler yeah i don't
think big j i think big j knows like old
school stuff but i don't know if he
watches his name he's like a die hard
wrestling fan taylor williamson taylor
williamson who's really funny i i don't
know ron though i'm surprised i didn't
ask ron actually
taylor williamson is if they ever make
and they should if they ever make a live
to action pinocchio
he's pinocchio doesn't he just look like
a little puppet boy he he has a look
about it he has a little innocence a
little puppet boy look he's very like
innocent in the way that he's the best
look at that yeah taylor williamson
there he is great kid taylor
he's a buddy of mine i've known taylor a
long time i love taylor you guys this
story is pretty crazy okay so ric flair
um was getting off a plane in richmond
virginia which is the state capitol in
which he was getting off a plane where
richmond virginia i will be there
october 28th at the carpenter theater at
7 p.m october 28th richmond virginia
state capital of virginia also the
former uh confederate capital capital of
the confederate states oh really that's
what it was it was richmond baby
um all right they didn't have the jet
ways back then back in the late 70s and
i was late for a match
i was a world champion then i was
wrestling ricky's steamboat at the
richmond coliseum wow finally they let
us all get off the plane i got off i was
walking i didn't get 10 15 feet and all
of a sudden i felt this pressure boom
and my umbrella shot 50 feet in the air
i thought what the hell lightning hit
the top of my umbrella bounced off and
hit a guy in the eye five feet behind me
and killed him what right there i just
stood there looking at the guy and froze
it scared me to death
wow
could you imagine well it looks like
he's been walking dead ever since really
so yeah let's get into it let's get into
it
could you imagine being killed because
you got
stabbed in the eye with
ric flair's lightning bolt umbrella
the odds the odds and you know like you
know what has to happen there at that
wake yeah do you know like the family of
that guy has to
be like no yeah no yeah no what you
heard is right he
rick flick i hit with lightning and then
the umbrella shot into the and then came
down and pierced philip and uh he died
from the lightning umbrella it went
right through his eyes yeah no hey thank
you so much no yeah what you heard is
right yes rick yeah we have it closed
because the umbrella went through he
didn't get struck by no no he did not
get struck by lightning directly yeah he
got ric flair the wrestler
hit his umbrella and then the umbrella
hit him in the eye thank you for coming
so much yes
he's here because he feels bad
his umbrella did yes exactly but he was
it wasn't rick player's fault lightning
yes lightning yes no rick flair no i
know he had cancer that's not what he
died from it's not he found cancer after
when they were trying to save his life
they found a mass on his gallbladder but
that ric flair didn't put it there now
yes so thank you thank you for coming
the umbrella is still in him in the cast
yes couldn't get it out we did yes ric
flair did take the umbrella back because
it was raining
ric flair is one of those guys there's
certain people i think we've talked
about this before in the pod there's
certain people that you think they're
dead but they're not and ric flair is in
that category where i think a lot of
people you had a couple health scares in
the last year not you because i know
you're you're you know a big wrestling
fan but people who are like you know
let's say peripheral wrestling fans they
would i think a percentage of them would
think ric flair is dead
i would agree with you you know who i
just had this thought about like not
more than a day ago is gene hackman
alive
oh what a good one right i'm going to
say before we pull it up pimp i'm going
to put my vote into this gene hackman is
alive i i thought he was alive too you
want to do this alive or dead ski yeah
where's gene hackman living today
this is in february 20th 2022 he's
living in
new mexico he has three children from
his first wife whose name is faye
maltese
[Laughter]
so he's alive he's alive but i believe
he stopped oh look acting 1956 2004 then
he retires acting became a novelist he's
been writing novels just writes novels
now wow i had no idea that's like jim
carrey's just a painter now not an actor
just paints is that true that's what
that's what they said sell his art for
money i believe he sells his own top
dollar yep i believe he sells his art
let's see if we can buy some of jim
carrey's right now maybe we'll
crowdsource the funds what do you got
yeah let's buy jim carrey's art what do
we got
oh art yeah
jim carrey's art okay here we go
jim carrey's art
yeah jim carrey art for sale but that's
going to be
jim carrey art ocean blue galleries here
we go oh my gosh oh here we go first
limited editions of jimmy jimmy
jim carrey's art on canvas oh you can
call and uh the place is in tampa
do you guys want to call them price
something
i mean can you oh so you can't get a
price online
click on hooray we are broken
can't even click on it
he's a phenomenal painter
yeah
jim carrey needed color did you ever see
that video he did where he gave a speech
i think it might have been like a
graduation yeah i think he gave this by
the way it just says jim carrey needed
color the title of that video should
have been jim carrey living in color oh
first things first let's see if we can
get a price on it second thing did you
ever see the video he gave of a speech
where it was like
it was like an amazing speech and then
he pulled the canvas and it was like a a
60-foot painting
no it's you should give it a go let's do
it it's it's an impassioned sweet you
see this look can i show you something
something to jerk off to later i got
these uh
now i keep i keep the tags on [ __ ] you
know whoa those are new nike shorts the
new nike basketball shots babe are they
awesome they're great they're
lightweight they have i love the tone of
blue they have the red goes you got them
online no i bought them in person nike
store where'd i buy them i bought them
at
motor three
it's a retail store it's a it's a like a
a
a a streetwear sneaker store in
milwaukee
milwaukee still never been there i mean
the fact that we still wear tassels on
graduation hats is just pretty pretty
funny and look at can i just say
something he i love jim carrey j you
know all that aside he looks like an
idiot he does in this picture
looks like he's wearing a couch pillow
on his head he does look dumb he looks
like a throw piece it literally looks
like he's dressing up to do an episode
of hey baby
it looks like a bit it's it's oh my god
should we get graduate that's what we
should get those because graduation time
is graduation time right now when does
this episode come out this is like three
weeks four weeks from now yeah
we should do a graduation special where
we each give commencement speeches we
should that commence with speeches and
you could try some of your ric flair
bits in there i can do it there you go
um yeah he looked like he had a tufted
velour uh couch throw pillow on his head
it's so this is one of his paintings
that he painted i'm not sure if this is
even the one i was talking about but i
think they went buck wild for him
i mean i i'd go buck wild if jim carrey
was my but it was i watched it it was a
good speech too like just talked a lot
like like it will it will inspire where
where is it masha raha university
maharsh maharsh
what school is that
maha harsh institution of universities
i don't know what he's saying
um i do jim carrey i would say when
people ask who's your favorite comedian
of all time you or who inspired you to
do comedy my answer usually is jim
carrey really stand up well yeah because
in the 90s you know when i was watching
living color in the early 90s and then i
all his movies the mask liar liar
or ace ventura's all those movies were
like i was like oh guys i would love to
be like that yeah dumb and dumber cable
guy yeah um you know what uh what's his
name is that's robert
oh it is it's so long i think he lives
on staten island or lived up to it he
did stop it he did he lived on or lived
in staten island dumb and dumber classic
um
so that's that's so yeah because i asked
you that i was trying i've been trying
to think this whole time of what is my
best moment of the week yeah just my
best moment of that could be a new
segment best moment it's very difficult
to find a moment yeah in anything i
would what has been my best
moment
um i would say my best just moment
oh
you know what it was
i
got um
ice cream for my kids on uh monday i got
ice cream for them and i got a reese's
peanut butter cups carvel anch from
carvel we've spoken about this before
the avalanche butt of carville okay
and i i didn't want anything i said you
know what i'm trying to get in shape
trying to lean out a little bit trying
to just get stronger in the gym i said
i'm not gonna eat that stuff i said so
um i said so
i'm just gonna get it for my kids and my
daughter delilah was eating it and she
ate half of it and she didn't want
anymore should i go daddy my stomach
hurt so i was gonna throw it away but i
noticed as i was throwing it away
because i was like willpower throw it
away my daughter's not going to eat ice
cream that's a day old
i just throw it away i noticed it was
almost like the light was hitting it a
chunk a half
chunk of a reese's peanut butter cup was
sticking out with vanilla ice cream and
chocolate syrup just dripping off like
its chin almost like it literally looked
like it was just it was dripping off the
peanut butter cup as if to say you need
to swallow me whole yeah and i took that
spoon yeah and i ate it yeah and that
was the best five seconds of my life was
that good i immediately went to the
bathroom and purged it and stuck my
finger down my throat and threw it up no
i'm kidding but have you ever done that
never in my life okay i never ever ever
would willingly make myself throw up and
i never ever ever would get surgery that
i didn't absolutely need
i don't care what happened to unless it
was a life or death situation i would
not get an elective surgery i would
never do it i don't believe so either i
just don't i just feel like you got to
just go with what god gave you what's
your take on botox
on botox i
i would never uh get it
um i personally think that aging never
gonna get it never gonna get it never
gonna get it
get into the grove baby you got to prove
your love to me
talk about grove
love groves let's talk about grove baby
let's talk about you and me let's talk
about all the good things and the bad
things bro maybe let's talk about grove
all right give me a g g you got your g
you got your g give me your r r you got
your r you got your r give me a o o you
got your o you got your o give me a v v
you got your v you got your v give me an
e e you got your e you got your e what
does it spell grow
grove
so i ordered from grove i have a uh
solid dish soap it's like a bar
and so i'm not using plastic right okay
so it's like a bar and it stays right at
my kitchen sink right there and then i
take the sponge and i kind of rub it on
there and that's how i that's my dish
soap you're a solid guy you need a solid
bar of soap that's why you use growth
that's right that's what i like and it's
twice as effective as the leading
natural brands they're friendlier to the
planet and we love friendly but what
they do is they they are an aggregate of
all different kinds of orga of conscious
brands they carry hundreds of products
aimed at replacing single-use plastics
across your home and personal care
routine by 2025 grove will be 100
plastic free 100
plastic free
go to grove.com
hey babe today join over two million
households to get a free gift set worth
up to 50 dollars with your first order
plus shipping is fast and free get
started right now at grove.com hey babe
that's
grove.com slash hey babe
oh
my
god all i got to say to you
is
america's number one
meal kids
hello fresh or our spanish-speaking
audience or la fresca ah hello freshness
my old friend
i've come to subscribe to you again
nice yes i heard that you have new
summer choices
choose from over 55 options weekly
featuring pre-portion high quality
ingredients customize your favorite
dishes
with hello custom by swapping out one
protein or adding a veggie meal skin
skip the grocery store and spend more
time soaking up summer sun hello fresh
market is a one-stop shop for all your
meal time needs with quick breakfast
lunches snacks desserts and more you get
them shipped right to your house you got
20 minute meals you got 30 minute meals
they have
just tons of options uh we love hello
fresh we talk about it every week talk
about it every week i use it sal uses it
pimp uses it we're all hello fresh guys
you can customize your what you get you
could swap out proteins you can add some
stuff it's way cheaper like 72 percent
cheaper than dining at a restaurant even
cheaper than the grocery store
uh come on i mean what are we doing here
you want to learn how to cook you want
to want to start you want to have an
activity to do with your kids or bring
your family together cooking is it
cooking is it and hellofresh is cooking
that's what it is
go to
hellofresh.com16 and use the code hey
babe 16 for up to 16 free meals and
three free gifts i told my daughter
you're not getting a sweet 16 you're
getting 16 free meals plus three free
gifts and she gave me a hug and said i
love you so much daddy you're the best
repeat it one more time baby
hellofresh.com
hey babe16 use the code hey babe 16 for
up to 16 free meals and three free gifts
um i think that aging is just a part of
living yeah and we should just celebrate
getting old as [ __ ] so i recently not
recently but like the last couple years
i f i got a line here
like because i squint so much because i
have bad eyesight and it finally caught
up to me and like became a perm so it's
like right here right and it wasn't
there like a few years ago and i it's
been annoying me
so you think you're gonna get talks no i
didn't think so but i had a friend of
ours and i won't say any names because i
don't know although they probably say
that they get talks all the time but
they were like just get talks
and i was like i'm a little nervous and
they said it's just some botch
in the face and it goes away i said but
what about those people that you see
they get so much that they like no
longer smile and then he says yeah but
that's not what it is you just get a
little bit you'll never know so many
people have botox and you don't even
know it because they do it the right way
you just don't want to get shot up all
in your grill so then i was like well
they said it's not it's safe and it goes
away and it's not a big deal and they
start to make a case for it because i've
never even entertained it for a split
second because in my head you're just
shooting botulism in your face and it's
it's but i know and then i found out
after he told me more people i knew that
did that do it that i didn't know
and then i'm like if it just takes out
this little line here and again never in
my life would i get elective search
never
you wouldn't i wouldn't but i think like
i don't know
it's like you go in you pay like a few
bucks they it takes like five minutes
and you leave that sounds like
that sounds like fair
yeah i feel like
you if you got addicted to botox i gotta
be honest with you it would be
like even though it would be like a
thing that we'd all deal with together
as your friends and family but secretly
we'd be laughing i mean a lot laughing
it would be because you would like the
catwoman face would be really really
really like hard to take funny yeah but
i would not
but i wouldn't get it that bad but i'm
saying if you've got an addiction i got
addicted to like everyone else nothing
could stop you you're addicted to tick
tocks i'm addicted to botox botox look
can we pull up the world the world the
worst botched uh worst botox the worst
protest
you know what it is it's just raging
insecurity what's raging in security
yeah
i look like the guy in the back
oh my god look at her face it's poor
thing
poor little girl they shouldn't be
allowed to do that to her no it's almost
the doctor's fault right
she looks like a cartoon
all right what about no what about like
worst worst plastic surgery there's that
woman jocelyne jocelyn wildenstein
yeah put put worst plastic surgery wild
and steam oh my god look at that little
face
oh
oh that can't be real dude it's just not
good
i mean at what point oh no
oh no
oh boy oh boy oh no
the one hold on the one laying in the
bed just a few back she was like i done
[ __ ] up yeah she was like she's like i
done went and i [ __ ] up yeah it's okay
look at my face a little bit more there
she's like please get out of my [ __ ]
face i hate my life but then if you fast
forward this other girl is out of the
hospital and she's got a parakeet on her
shoulder and she's like i've accepted
this and this looks good look at that
woman's eye that that's that can't be
real that can't be real is that a filter
yeah
let's go to number one
that's monkey
pox number one is that woman that's her
this is her yeah joyce wildenstein she
looks like a full she looks like a like
a like a sphynx cat yes she does she
looks like a cat wait i have a question
like is she like what does she do and is
she alive and well and she must know
that she
she made a few wrong turns at
albuquerque and she can't come back from
it but i'm not here to
put her down so much as to understand
how and why
how and why is what we're trying to get
to the bottom of is a little how and why
i think it's jocelyn
wildenstein good luck spelling it uh
pimp spelled before he spelled uh
i don't know what what'd you spell
before
analogous analogous joe was like i'm
gonna i'm gonna give you an analogous
sentence and i was like okay i don't
know if analogous is what i know you
mean analogy he goes no it is he goes
type it in we turned it we started
cracking up we were like pimp
could take 200 times and not spell
analogous and he got on the first try
something happened today where pimp
put lettuce together in a row that and
he now just lucked out yeah i mean yeah
because but that's usually how it goes
is people who can't spell easy words can
spell insanely hard words yeah that's
what it is well look at her in the 70s
you know you get where she's coming from
that's crazy because because because in
98 she was already like i done [ __ ] up
and then five years later in 2003 she's
like let me i would be like all right
let's pump the brakes is that a real
picture from 2008 because honestly again
i'm not here to shame but if that person
was walking in the street it's so
unnatural it'd be jarring here's what
happens is i'll be honest is is we're
looking at these pictures right now and
pimp we could put them up in the up is
in 1970s she looks like an old person
then 1998 she looks out of control nuts
2003 she gets even worse but then 2008
somehow she starts to look more like she
did in 1970s she almost just comes full
circle with her plastic surgery oh my
lord dude that is i want to know if
that's real that top left one
yeah it is
i mean she said you know she's like
listen my last name's wildstein i'm a
wild child
i um men that get plastic surgery is
pretty weird
men that get it seems like almost every
billionaire that you see
has a lot of plastic surgery besides
bill gates
almost every other billionaire has big
do you think so you think musk has
yeah i think muscle i mean you ever see
musk before and afters no do elon musk
before and after i think he's had some
work done he's got hair implants
yeah see oh [ __ ]
oh look at him before the plants look at
jeff bezos dude he looks like the rock
now actually he looks a little bit in
that picture like taylor williamson a
little bit cause wasn't he in a blue
wasn't he just in a blue color oh my god
his hair is a little bit the same taylor
williamson plays elon musk before elon
had one of his life and then the actual
elon musk we know is played by who who
plays the actual elon
who looks like that
i don't know
where we going here oh before and afters
okay
yeah before and after plastic surgeries
are you but see the thing is when you
botch a plastic surgery yeah it just
it just sucks and i think there must be
tons of emotional trauma that come with
that because you know that nobody made
you do this it's you that dumb [ __ ] up
yeah it's it's it's it's you did this
and you decided to do this and you have
to feel like why did i do this like well
that's what it is it has to be
something's bothering them so much that
they need to change it the only thing is
like i wonder if whatever they end up
with if if popular opinion would say the
new thing doesn't look right maybe
they're
they don't care it's like it's better
than what i had i heard that when you
get breast implants as a woman even
though even i guess as a man too
even even though
you might feel better because you've
opened up your chest
something happens like with the cells
inside your body that it makes you
insanely depressed same thing when you
get a heart transplant really it makes
you insanely depressed because you're
opening up your chest and there's
something that science just doesn't
understand yet about like a connection
to your emotions through that i've been
watching you ever watch the unexplained
on netflix with william shatner were you
guys talking about it i just mentioned
it off-camera okay so so i just saw an
episode maybe it's not william shatner i
don't know it's it's different episodes
of something right yes
so so the one that i was just watching
uh last night
was about this about um
you know heart about transplants you see
the guy that got a pig heart and and it
was it took for a couple of months and
they passed like last month it was the
first ever pig to human heart transplant
last month interesting couple months ago
my god i wish i wish derosa should have
been the first one for that
um
i feel uh so so what what i learned was
i'm sorry what it was saying in the
unexplained was is that
is that
this woman this girl 17 year old girl
who had a some rare liver disease and
was going to die right and needed to get
a liv lay down and it was
so
needed to get a liver just yeah hang out
you need to get a liver transplant yeah
okay she got this liver transplant from
this 47 year old guy who had died in a
car accident like three days before
so she gets the liver transplants she
survives she's getting healthy on her
feet again whatever whatever whatever
she then
all of a sudden out of nowhere
starts to have this unbelievable desire
to start doing all her housework
do-it-yourself job she's putting down
her own flooring she's reconstructing
the bathroom she's taking tiles out
she's a handy woman now because this guy
in his heart this guy was a freaking
construction worker that she got
delivered i don't believe that i swear
to god i swear to god you know it's
crazy to be thinking that you are
driving right now you get into an
accident and three days later it was a
liver of heart liver to read imagine
like you leave here and then three days
later your liver is in someone else's
body and they're doing and they're just
doing stand-up comedy they have this
desire to stand up
and i i gave i gave it to like uh you
know some filipino girl but she's just
doing bits about her puerto rican kids
and her and her mafia father
but it was interesting because it's
it's it's
you know a lot science would think oh
your talent and your thoughts and your
memories would only be in your brain but
they think that actually now you are
like we are who we are our personality
and our traits are dispersed through
every cell in our body that's why these
billions of cells in this person's liver
transferred to the little girl and now
she started acting like him and just
putting down her own flooring but i
started mixing cement for no reason
i could see like a biochemical
like something like about there the mood
or whatever but like it feels weird to
be like
in my body like in within my cells that
i transfer to you like i'll teach you
how to use a hacksaw that's but that's
what that's what
okay you got a high interest debt high
interest credit yeah you got stuff you
got you got you're trying to get
yourself out of a hole you're trying to
pay your debt down all of a sudden you
got a bill dropped on you medical bill
that you can't cover you can't cover it
at all
i got i got the place for you all online
with simple and easy understand payment
terms it gives you one place one way to
get all your debt down upstart it's not
you're not hopeless there's a light at
the end of the tunnel this is where
upstart comes in you get rid of that
high interest credit card debt and you
get towards your financial freedom one
closer step towards your financial
freedom but the interest month after
month usually is like it feels like it's
never ending we've all been there and
look up start is powered personal loans
that can help you pay down high interest
debt like you said all online with
simple and easy to understand payment
terms they've helped over 1.8 million
customers so far again whether it's
paying off your debt consolidating your
debt funding a personal expense upstart
can help you get one fixed monthly
payment all the way up start don't wait
and check your rate today at upstart.com
hey babe that's
upstart.com hey babe to check your rate
today don't forget to use our url to let
them know we sent you loan amounts will
be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
hey vape and within minutes the loans
can be from one thousand and fifty
thousand dollars
the new sciences like pimp has just
pulled up i saw this yesterday too
this guy got a head injury he fell and
hit his head and then all of a sudden he
woke up and he's playing music like he's
mozart yeah difficult to believe so
there's things without training
very few people in the world
like this happen our rick salinger tells
us how an accident revealed a deeply
hidden talent what the man calls his
beautiful disaster
the music is in his mind
his fingers do the rest
what derek amato has is a gift a gift
that came in the most unexpected way it
happened 12 years ago in a swimming pool
accident i miscalculated diving towards
the shallow end
and i struck the bottom
of the shallow end on this side of my
head
after recovering he was at a friend's
house and walked over to a keyboard and
suddenly without having played before
his hands were all over it no way having
never played before
that's just called the region
syndrome the trauma to the head unlocks
something unique inside derek amato's
brain
so why can't we do this
at will
like why can't they understand how that
because that's what they're saying like
we only they think maybe you always hear
oh you only use 10 of your brain they
think it's even less now they think most
humans can use one to two percent of
their brain and a true
mind-blowing human let's say like an
elon musk can use like five percent
so they think like when you traumatic
brain injuries happen or certain things
happen somehow that part of their brain
gets like unlocked to very close to or
higher percent of its full capacity and
they can do that there's so many people
there's a guy who um got uh i think
struck by lightning not ric flair
somebody got struck by lightning and
they could speak all different languages
that's the funnest it's just it's just
like we haven't looked up that means all
our brains have babble locked inside of
it right every single one of our brains
have have a friend we have a language
learning app for life in our brains
already i mean we still encourage you to
go to babble.com use your promo code hey
babe but it all gets struck by lightning
and then it'll unlock yeah there's 14
different languages it's done not by ai
but by language uh learning exercises
which are in your [ __ ] brain yeah and
it's a fun way it's cognitive way to
remember and they have 20-minute lessons
15-minute lessons it's a lot of fun here
we go so this kid
um
what did we ever look them up where they
get hitting their head and they start
talking another language because that
was what we should look up right now
well look at this guy why do people wake
up from coma speak in other languages so
go down a little bit pimpy so this guy
reuben nezuma a teenager from atlanta
has made international headlines after
waking up from a coma speaking fluent
spanish a language he had only had a
basic understand understanding of before
he had struggled to speak english after
suffering the concussion during a
football game and then he just started
speaking spanish
every time he felt like he was about to
try to speak english he felt like he was
going to have a seizure it said yeah
that's how much he hated english he was
like i only need no only habla espanoles
yeah dude it's a real wow some this
australian man woke up and started
yeah i don't know man by the way
speaking of have you ever been to wales
i want to go to
wales like you can't imagine most
castles per square foot
whales
yeah you went to uh um uh cardiff yeah
and you loved it i loved it did you stay
in a castle i went to the castle you
went to cardiff castle i went to the
like a big castle was it i walked all
around it it was on the grounds with
another castle
like i was i i did it you went castle
hopping before the show i went castle
i'm not kidding
and in cardiff my boy um my boy lives
out there he's a writer and director of
films
and he lives in wales
yeah
so did you go to visit pull up
yeah i went uh no not that one
cardiff castle it's right in the middle
of cardiff yeah i went
i need to go to waste maybe maybe that
was it maybe one of those that was it i
think
that one right there no no to the left i
think that was it yeah to the left to
the how come the democrats don't do that
typing type in the the uh the raid
yeah actually he's doing uh he's doing
uh he's directing tom hardy in a movie
right now really yes carrot carrot right
there
right there yeah yeah that's your friend
yeah
i want if i go to wales can can i go
sleep at his house
i'm going to uk in october to do shows
hopefully wales is on gareth hugh evans
gareth evans yeah not hugh evans i i
only i mean to me gareth evans how did
you meet gareth evans
he
we were a fan of his movies the raid and
the raid 2 and subsequent movies and he
has he's an amazing amazing director
like no you don't even know like he did
like the raid is what inspired like john
wick and like okay and that kind of
thing i got to see the raid oh my dude
it's amazing and he's since made a bunch
of movies and i'm telling him show up by
just calling out the raid but he did
another one called apostles on netflix
and went into that and now he's working
on a movie with with tom hardy he is the
nicest dude in the world he's like your
age i think and he was a fan of our show
he was a fan of our show we met him we
went out there we hit it off with him
became friends and now every time i went
back i would see him and when he comes
here he'd visit us here and he's a great
dude does he have a view of a castle
from his house i don't believe so no but
nice house to fly him to his house
i want to go visit gareth in wales i'm
telling you right now the
shout out to gareth everybody shout out
to gareth of wales yeah i have a friend
named gareth reynolds but he lives in
california i guarantee is a comedian you
know gareth reynolds yes he's from
wisconsin so you have garrett of wales i
have gareth of wisconsin yeah it's the
same thing um um
yeah i was saying i thought that
for the midterms coming up this year the
democrats if they want to win they
should do they should remake
uh beyonce's song to the left to the
left but go but go uh uh to the left to
the left give me all your votes in the
box to the left
right yeah and then we could keep doing
it that's pretty good i can't have
another you in a minute uh yeah right
is that you must not know about me
isn't it or is it is it or is beyonce i
don't understand y'all gonna have
another trump in a minute if you don't
put those votes to the left um viral
tick tock details man allegedly air
dropping photo of penis to other pastors
on a flight okay let's get into it i
want to see i want to see the tick tock
if you somehow had a picture of your
penis on your phone and you accidentally
airdropped it to people on the flight
you were with just what happened oh if i
i told you i think you could say if i
accidentally received let's talk through
both okay so if i accidentally received
it this is what i do
i i'd be looking at my phone i go like
this
and then i tap the person next to me and
go
someone just air dropped that's me on
this on this fight you would show the
person next to you the penis that you
just got i mean i think i'd have to yeah
i'd be like can you believe that oh like
if they were traveling with you yeah
like if it was you oh you'd be like
yeah oh then no then no i probably
wouldn't say i then i just like oh my
god i feel like bad for this person if i
actually did it though if i was the one
who actually did it i'm not kidding i
probably would try to open up the
emergency exit
aaron jump out with no parachutes get
out of the way
no it's pretty cool his name's larry he
larry who just airdropped a whole flight
photos of his pp thankfully i accepted
it saw who was sending it
thankfully i accepted it saw who was
sending it and immediately started
speaking up
stay tuned for the police escort
it was great hearing lady go photos of
his pee pee
[Music]
what is she saying is that him right
there
that's him that's him that's larry air
dropped his [ __ ]
he goes sorry about that
i can't hear it
she's saying it's assault
he said having a little fun
meet larry who just airdropped
there's a
thing hey larry do you have a tic toc
[Music]
hey larry do you have a tick-tock
oh darn oh
and the text that says he air-dropped it
to kids too
ah okay i know people are asking for an
update a few of us had to meet with an
fbi agent who told us larry was arrested
and will be spending the weekend in
whatever airport jail looks like
whatever airport looks like if i get an
update i will there was a child who had
sent the photo but didn't approve the
airdrop his dad was ready to fight
outside of that we all got statements
and we're told to wait for a phone call
and we may get updates what a day
kind of also to be honest with you can i
just be honest
it also kind of feels like this lady has
nothing to do in her life at all and
she's like what a day it's because you
know what the truth was is you were
probably landing and you have zero to do
in your life so you were just like let
me just cause an uproar should he have
sent an airdrop to dick pic of course
not does is it horrible yeah but you're
getting the fbi involved it's like just
tell this guy that you're gonna punch
him in the [ __ ] head and move on and
the kid who got airdropped the photo
didn't even accept it let his father
deal with that not you if these people
dude people the attention seeking [ __ ]
people are just bother me to no end even
though larry does look like an absolute
pedophile
larry's looks not doing him any favors
now let me ask you this if larry had a
[ __ ] thick
huge gorgeous peepee and was jacked and
ripped i wonder if this lady would have
cared at all she would yeah she would
the fbi be involved i don't know i i i'd
be a local authority maybe exactly
that's what i was going to say the local
authorities but i mean i what would you
do would you tell the flight attendant
if you got air dropped somebody's pissed
a deal
what would you do if you got a dick
to you right in the middle of the airway
i i it was to me i wouldn't i would
maybe maybe like
maybe take it up with the guy but if i
did see him send it to like women or
children like
here's an important deed was that a
mortifying mistake
or was he literally trying to airdrop
his like did he have that much was he
that idiotic that he would air drop his
penis to strangers on the same plane he
was on
did it say
um
it says the picture was this said the
photo being shared was a picture of a
woman's face giving larry head
a woman's face wait what
he there's no way he meant to see that's
the other thing is there's no way he
meant to air drop it to everyone he said
i looked over and said are you larry and
he said yes i am i was first his
instagram account is daddy strange 333.
oh he she look she said he she yeah yeah
she said that
she said did you mean to send me this
and larry said yes i did
so what's up with larry then
yeah maybe i'm i guess whatever i take
back what i said before maybe larry's a
dick and needs to well if he's if he
yeah yeah i guess if he meant to do i
was assuming he didn't mean to do it
and it was just an accidentae but i
guess daddy strange three through three
is saying she did mean he did mean to do
it
whatever who spot him got him my airdrop
is never on a famous young rapper never
spot him got him he's like uh the hot
young rapper fled from police on a jet
ski i just thought that's so wild oh was
that like oh it's like in a bond movie
spot him got him
isn't that what they're going to do with
him spawn him
he spot him got him i see him on the jet
ski yeah but what's his position
got him
no but where is he knows he named
himself the thing that happens to him
most often
i spotted spot him got him got him
[ __ ] wait they spotted me no the police
called the search like he got him no i
didn't chase still changing spot i spot
him do you got him no spot him spot him
got him
um what would oh what did he have on a
jet ski at an ar-15 on him all right
well
yeah
very interesting
spot him got him look out for all his
new stuff coming out on spotify on spot
him got him five
so he's on a jet ski with an ak-47
let me ask you a question dwight oh
jetski am i out of touch like how did
you know who spot him got him was well i
just listened to all the trending music
okay and spiderman got him was trending
recently
is he has he been a thing so he's been a
thing for a year he's on the radar of
becoming do we know any of his songs or
no way
have you ever heard of him never heard
of spot him right i was gonna say like
he's been on the radar for a year you
think with a name like spot him got him
i would have heard of him i mean he
looks like a fun kid
you know
you think i would have heard him seen
him i think i would yeah you know what i
mean
i never heard him seen him spot him got
him why does every single rapper right
now
have the same haircut and face tattoos
yeah every and jay-z's hair is like this
now too oh it's a basketball thing
actually yeah oh basket oh this looks
less like a like a whatever those boys
were and that looks more like a
basketball basket's lower east side from
the lower side yeah all right what is he
an artist right michelle yeah boss he's
past but he was he was a very young
prolific
like uh i mean he was in the whole time
of like that pop art that punk pop
renaissance in the lower east side like
andy warhol that whole that whole he was
that era like he was new andy warhol he
was yeah he knew him yeah so but he was
he was younger than me he died at 27 too
i think right isn't he got part of the
27 club
gelain maxwell's sentence to 20 years at
prison allegedly
you know what she should do what take it
up bloom cafe
i wonder if they'll endorse that
yeah
um
they uh uh she got 20 years colleen
maxwell so when this might have this
might be two three weeks delay maxwell
might be hung in prison did you hear
what she said too
pimp what was it she was like to all the
people that got like hurt look at her
i'm sorry and i hope you i hope you
what'd she say here's the quote to you
to you
to
to you to you
to you all all the victims who came in
court and those outside i am sorry for
the pain that you experienced
i hope my conviction
and harsh incarceration brings you
closure that's it that's that's she's
not being
i don't know she's calling it a harsh
harsh incarceration
so that means she's being like
she's being petty about it have we ever
heard her speak i don't even know no
nobody hears her speak gallane maxwell
and she got sentenced to 20 years she's
60. she couldn't she might get out of
jail
if she gets out with like 10 with good
behavior or
was that a picture of her she looked
like she got some plastic surge
yeah no that's not her is that her
family that's one of the accusers
oh one of the accused the guy in the
back looks jacked
um
that's one of the accusers okay okay
a lot of court cases going on a lot of
court cases a lot of people getting sued
you ever watch the old people's court
with judge wapner are you too young for
that it was like the
og of court room television the people's
court starring judges
people's court so judge wapner so
people's call was like a pre-wreck to
judge judy oh big like it was it there
was no there's no judge judy without
judge wabner
judge okay so shannon want to shout out
judge wapner did you ever hear this
that's the music to it
yeah
yeah
and they're like the defendant is suing
his neighbor yes he says okay so judge
wapter would he go in on people
oh no one nobody have to [ __ ]
nobody after them
and he was awesome he was awesome let's
play the game judge joseph wapner dead
or alive oh man i gotta say dead only
because i watch him growing up and
that's what he looked like when i grew
up
let's see
please be alive i hope you're alive
i hope you're alive judge died in 2017
not too long five years ago
five years ago feb 26
2017 we lost i bet you this is like the
best of on youtube like the judge
yeah man do you know that that that
judge jude's is like like she's worth
like a half a billion dollars or
something you know her husband is worth
like three times the money is she now
she is yeah so when she goes home he's
like how's your little tv show he's a
big google judge judy's husband's net
worth
judge yeah she's got a 460 million
dollar fortune but i think her husband
is worth like 10 times as much money i
think her husband's like a
multi-billionaire 550 million is what
her husband is serious yeah are you
serious yep wait do you know that i
don't know how accurate these things are
but do you understand what it means for
her to be worth 400 million meaning like
she has all her assets in cash and
everything combined she's worth they're
saying she's worth 400 million which
means she's made a billion dollars like
you can't like less less taxes like god
she's saying she's she's a net worth
dude you know what her salary is still
yearly i think if she's still doing new
episodes or once it was she was highest
paid act highest paid person in
television history like 15 years in a
row you know what her salary was for
judge judy a year her salary
million dollars a year away judge judy's
salary a year no take her to court 47
million dollars a year folks so i
finagled it by 8 mil
oh my god yeah she's making lebron james
money wait wait wait wait wait wait go
down what does that say it's not
excessive i wonder what the
right judge judy's can you click on that
judge judy's 47 million dollar salary
isn't excessive who's worth 47 million
dollars a year who
um
who's worth it yeah
uh jay leno and david letterman are
getting no more than 28 million a year
she's doubled them
yep
but why why does she make that is it are
the ratings that high yeah i think it's
a every daily show their ratings are
probably that high she's been on tv
forever making her one the highest paid
person on television she made more money
than seinfeld
yeah in subsequent negotiations she
would slip her boss's dollar figures in
sealed envelopes across the table
oh my god dude
there you go
391 000 per epic weapon
yeah she's oh my god she's joe rogan i
gotta get on judge judy yeah she's she's
she's joe rogan dude how about she an
episode is 20 minutes
an episode is 20 minutes she probably
films an entire season of judge judy in
like three weeks if i was judge judy
dude i'm not kidding
name a place name a place anything from
bora bora a bora bora name something
specific like anything from let's just
name it like like
like a specific city no i mean like a
specific like literal location like like
an address um um i'm uh 16
1655 queens boulevard but i just mean
name name what it is is it is it this
building is it yankee stadium is it oh
okay name anything the o2 arena o2 arena
if i was judge judy
i would walk i would fly there i'd go
into
the o2 arena with my gown on right nude
underneath i get right to send i get on
stage i lift my gown up if i was judge
judy yeah i would squat and i would [ __ ]
on the stage that's what you do and i
drop my gown down and i just be like and
i just like moon walk out
if i was judge judy on the last episode
of my show because i've made so much
money on the very last episode of the
very last court case i would swear to
god i would hit that gavel thing that
gavel i'd hit it right with my [ __ ] i
would bump my [ __ ] right off it nude on
the air live episode i just moved the
candy i would bump it right there and
say that's what you get i think she
should do whatever she wants she should
judge you should start an only family
she should [ __ ] my hands throw to people
why the hell not she's got monkey pox
she should throw it she should start an
only fans if i was her i would do some
weird stuff like just get like a dixon
onto my hand or something how about this
pat sajak from wheel of fortune earns 14
mil vanna white earns 10 million dollars
a year that is from best job i'd rather
do would you rather do
judge judy's job every day in court and
make 47 million a year or vanna white's
job every day in the studio and turn the
letter dude vanna white's job in a
heartbeat i do it for free now teaching
my kids how to read i point at different
letters and ask them to read the
sentence vanna white is getting 10
million dollars a year for it joe hit me
up with vanna white's net worth
10 million we no that's that's where
they're worth i know what's right i know
it's got to be a hundred shmill this is
a fun game to play okay was net worth
oh my god i just saw
it 85 billion
85 million dollars 85 million folks on
vanna white that's it i mean never you
don't need judge judy money like that's
more than you could ever spend listen
how easy vanna white's job is they start
calling her vanna white privilege
[Laughter]
how about this why she why doesn't she
stop
why would she stop
well because what you got to do is turn
lighters around
she's she's more 19. does anyone have a
bigger forehead than pat sajak it's up
to she's 65 that's it
she's like bless her when did she start
oh she's got a daughter she's the she's
not enough people talk about her anymore
like yeah she is unique in that she is
super rich super famous and
i mean super super famous like wheel of
fortune is iconic pop culture she's
attached right to it if not more so than
pat sajak
and but she doesn't she hasn't done
anything besides play that role vanna
white makes 10 million 10 million
dollars a year no one has ever heard her
talk
i know she never speaks she she speaks a
little but i know what you mean almost
she's i bet you
she has said the fewest words on
television made the most money
i guarantee you're right about that yeah
and also did you see that she wasn't the
first letter turner there was a lady
that left oh who's that oh you know she
should be taking the gavel and slamming
herself and that's what she should be
doing yeah
the lady that left
we're all over the charts here look at
vanna she looks
unbelievable also i bet you that is
there vanna is a very uncommon name
this is a year ago that's her shoe she
looks like now yeah that's her that is
her house she lives in the museum those
are her family's photos she lives in a
straight up what am i supposed to say
the show must go on so i said yes i had
no training or experience i just jumped
in and did it and i was scared to death
well but you've see i mean you've seen
it
for many years it probably
came to you quite naturally i would like
my father still to this day calls her
kelly riper
i'm like it's kelly ripa and then it's
like oh yeah and then her back did you
see the new cali riper
and like i'm like it's ripa but i guess
it is pronounced riper ripa i don't care
because ripa
kelly ripa should be r-i-p-p-a that's
true but she spells it r-i-p-a i bet you
it is riper and she says ripper just to
be yeah because who's saying ripper for
that nobody you know the stefano volcano
it's the stefano volcano right it's
volcano
right nobody gets it right nobody ever
scott right
when you get cold on stage 50 50 shot
usually it's christie's usually it's
it's it's chris stefano or usually it's
christie stefano even though it's chris
it's chris stefano but you've heard
people pronounce that both ways that's
the thing i've never i've never heard of
another volcano i've never corrected
anyone i don't care you don't care i
don't either people get so caught up
right before i go on they're like can
you just tell me can you say now like
it's volcano like volcano volcano
volcano i'm like just say anything it
doesn't matter people get so mad at
everything like on chrissy chaos the
other day i started talking about um uh
roe v wade because of the whole like
overturned thing and people are up in
arms about jokes i was making just
yelling at me and now i'd like to take a
moment to tell you on hey babe what i
think of roe v wade okay this has been
hey baby
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe